this is a new show
on Apple TV
just launched starring Hillary and
Chelsea Clinton take a listen Chelsea
follows rap music she has ever since she
was a little girl
but I kind of came to awareness of you
with the cardi B WAP
I've always wanted to do a song with
cardi as soon as she sent me the song I
think I sent it back to her like the
next day and it was just so exciting the
men they seemed so confident in what
they're saying and they don't have no
problem with talking about their
sexuality and how they gonna have sex
with you so I was like well
I can do that and it's gonna Sound fire
coming from a woman it's great to see
women be so kind of fierce that is my
life's mission to make sure that I'm
always unapologetically me
we need a doctor at the daily wire we
need I need immediate medical attention
for the the permanent cringe that is
stuck on my face I don't I don't know
that I have any hope of recovery
it's it's always so wonderful wouldn't
you say a generic ethnic musician that
we've cast that we've obviously never
heard of uh wouldn't you say it's so
wonderful when women are fierce
now don't you think uh listen I'm not
the not the greatest hip-hop Aficionado
but by golly my daughter Chelsea she's
totally down with the Jive uh Chelsea
come on spit a few bars to our our
friend over here it's
I am
embarrassed for them
for Chelsea and for Hillary
and for everyone involved in this show
we there are too many shows there are
too many podcasts there's too too many
digital shows I'm calling for a complete
and total shutdown on new digital
content until we figure out what the
hell is going on
they could have Hillary and Chelsea
could have walked in dressed as Steve
Buscemi holding a skateboard and said
how do you do fellow aggrieved
minorities
hey yeah but isn't it so awful when the
man keeps us down and it would have been
it would have read as more genuine and
sincere you want to know why people are
fleeing this party maybe because you
guys are so ludicrously so ludicrously
out of touch that not a single normal
person in America can possibly relate to
you a Texas teacher has just been fired
that's the good news
after telling students not to judge
pedophiles
that's the bad news that's the bad news
for what for what the teacher was fired
for and they only found out because of a
short social media video in which the
teacher instructed the students not to
judge pedos and to instead to use the
politically correct term minor attracted
persons
minor attracted persons no don't judge
people just because I want to have sex
with above Europe
don't judge people just because they
want to have sex with five-year-olds
don't call them pedos they are minor
attracted persons
once again just have to remind people
that the conservatives told you so that
the social conservatives and the
traditionalists have been right about
every single thing ever for of all time
and at the time whenever we say anything
we're told that we're crazy and
hysterical and alarmist and we're
falling into a slippery slope fallacy
and every single time on every single
thing we've been correct
I remember when I first encountered the
term map minor attracted person some
years ago I thought it was a joke it was
in some article they said they're going
to start calling them minor attracted
person soon and I said you know actually
if you follow the logic of the libs
especially on the weird sex stuff they
probably will and I mentioned this and
my friend said oh you're crazy this is
ridiculous you're hysterical they are
now using even if it started out as a
joke they are now using this term
earnestly
so the school fired her uh and the
woman's 53 years old
and the uh the school said look we
looked into this we gave her the benefit
of the doubt we thought maybe she was
being sarcastic we we
did everything we could but there have
apparently been other incidents and
things that have not been disclosed to
the public and the school board just
said they voted unanimously they said we
got to get rid of this lady
of course now the thing you got to ask
yourself is
what's wrong with her argument
we all know that pedophilia is
disordered we have every right to judge
pedophilia pedophiles should be
certainly uh discouraged from pursuing
their desires or stating their desires
or it that is the sort of thing that if
anything should be stigmatized it should
be that
but what's wrong with her argument
her argument is that pedophiles are born
this way right they're born with their
desire to
have sex with children and I guess the
science is open about this I don't know
I it's hard to imagine why someone would
choose to be a pedophile they might
become a pedophile through acculturation
or some trauma that they've gone through
but regard that still wouldn't be their
choice right it's hard to imagine why
someone would choose to become a
pedophile so they didn't choose it they
were born this way or it happened to
them without their consent
so then why should why should it be
stigmatized they had no choice
in and in our culture consent and choice
is the only thing that we're told that
really matters
so why
and unfortunately we all know I think
it's still too far for the conservatives
to to adopt a kind of permissive
attitude toward minor retracted persons
but the conservatives have bought this
argument on so many other issues
well you can't judge people for this ad
or the other thing well you know if it's
if it's innate if it's natural if it's
come to them through acculturation you
know uh that's okay as long as it's just
a desire
that may that they're not acting out on
children that let's say they're just
looking at pornography or they're just
coming up with fantasies and they're or
let's say they've just got an interest
group you know uh what was the one in
NAMBLA the the man boy love group if
it's look if they're just advocating for
it then you know that's their right to
do that no of course that's insane of
course the conservative argument is nope
that's that desire is disordered it
should not be tolerated at all even as a
desire it should be deeply stigmatized
and anyone who feels it in any way
should should keep their mouth shut
about it okay
absolutely call pedos pedos and not let
them near our kids right that's that's
the norm but
for the people who buy the language of
choice and consent and liberalism and
this it's hard to see why it's wrong go
to epicwell.com use promo code Knowles
you know there's a story we've been
following at the daily wire a an actress
just died unexpectedly and it she did
not leave a will and as a result of this
she left her 20 year old son not only to
obviously be grieving his mother but to
be filing all the court papers to try to
control her estate it's just an absolute
mess a lot of people don't have Wills
they don't think about it don't let that
be you okay head on over to epicwill.com
to get it taken care of sweet little
Elise and I just got ours our Wills
squared away very recently and you just
have to do it okay do you want do you
want your kids to have to deal with that
do you want do you want I don't know the
government to come in and decide what
happens with your kids or with your
stuff absolutely not take five ten
minutes Square this thing away you go to
epicwill.com use promo code at null save
10 on Epic Will's complete will package
that's epicwill.com promo code Knowles
head on over there right now save 10
percent you you can square away your
whole estate you can do it very very
quickly but get it done epicwill.com
promo code Knowles
I'm so glad you like that clip now
ring that Bell subscribe get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]